[Musique]
oh c'est super beau Josh, à quand remonte
la dernière [ __ ] de méchante méchante mauvaise
pop girl
[Applaudissements]
le meilleur travail du monde
bien plus amusant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je t'aime bien
pourrais-je demander qui es-tu,
c'est vraiment comme débloquer  quelque chose en moi,
elle a eu une année difficile, la presse a
été brutale,
les anges, ouais, on peut parler d'un
angle, je veux dire, c'est un peu comme si
elle était à genoux,
la musique pop est comme le cheval de Troie ultime,
tu fais danser les gens, tu as  les gens
pour chanter, allez, donnez-m'en plus, je
veux être le plus grand groupe de tournée de tous les temps,
j'ai une [ __ ] d'idée géniale,
je n'ai pas vu de conneries pareilles depuis le
lavage de cerveau des années 90, je vous promets qu'il y a une nouvelle
Jocelyn qui arrive, d'accord,
bonjour les anges